what is it Lucas hey this is actually -
Fred Fred I just have a real quick
question man are you doing doing alright
this is our Q 3 rain over the drops in
terms of you can play a drop anytime
pretty much I'm not talking to Fred to
give him direction
honestly fred has free rein to do what
he wants and the real reason I don't
give them any direction is because I
then I get trapped in a conversation
with him so it's better we don't so it's
but ever we're doing seems to be working
so I never well people go give her like
train Fred like a train Fred what are
you a dog I chose to work with Fred
because I thought he was funny so Fred
receives no direction right I do not
fred is like a wild animal he's feral I
don't attempt to train him in any way he
doesn't even know how to use the litter
box he shits in the street bridge drops
are a big part of the show everyone
loves it it's a piece of the show that
people often comment on that they love
but a lot of times over the years even
we rob and forget where these drops came
it's true here it is here's one that you
hear all the time and you know who this
is
right Marc the beggar but you don't
remember when he said it no I don't in
2016 we were interviewing him about his
sex life and he dropped this amazing
quote that lives on in Fred's drops you
ever use a [ __ ] ring now no Ronnie
recommends that keeps you harder or
something yeah Robin has no idea how
great [ __ ] is explain it to her awesome
[ __ ] is the greatest that's where it
came from Robin I'll be trying to teach
you about [ __ ] he was the one who tell
me here's one we know who that is of
course the type is Eric he has an
attraction to certain men he's attracted
to TV weather guys Donnie Wahlberg and
on statements and Chris Wright any way
an email to Gary led to this dispute
over Eric's fascination with Donnie and
this is how that clip came about why did
you send Gary a note saying you
whoa [ __ ] Andy Cohen what did you say I
think I want to [ __ ] Andy Cohen
and no no wait a second another one Gary
I would [ __ ] Adam Levine now over Donny
Wahlberg Donny here
he's only gay for like a dozen men by
the way I want to point that out
all right you ready for another one okay
you like this yeah okay listen to this
you know who that is that's me way back
in 2006 Robyn got into a fight with Gary
over having to move out of her booth she
loves her news booth and you started
making this cat-like noise which is this
arguing going on sir that's you robbing
you that's what the audience hears from
you Wow you were high on green juice if
you love all that you can hear more
origins in the power of drops special
hosted by Fred mr. drops Norris we
actually it wasn't easy he bolts out of
here quicker than Benji at the end of
the show and yeah that's on the Sirius
XM app it's up there for your listening
pleasure wonderful it's a special and
everyone loves it special especially
when you get to get Fred on it is
special listening to